hi today i'll be talking to you about an
exciting new capability google cloud has
developed called apogee adapter for
envoy
[Music]
the goal of apogee adapter for envoy is
to help you integrate
envoy-based services into your apigee
environment
this means you could do things like
publish your services as apis
make them visible to other developers
add governance capabilities to control
access to those apis and analyze usage
metrics to see how your apis are being
consumed
let's talk a little bit more about how
we do this
behind the scenes apogee adapter for
envoy uses envoy's external
authorization filter
which is designed to allow envoy to
delegate authorization decisions to an
external system
in this demo i'll show you how to use
envoy to protect
an endpoint i'll add an envoy facade on
it which is configured to talk to the
apogee adapter for envoy
let's dive in i have an api product
which in apogee is the subscription
point or what consumers subscribe to to
begin with i have nothing configured in
this api product
the first step is to bind the endpoint
httpbin.org
to the api product with this command
i've just entered
we have provided a cli which allows you
to add the endpoint
httpbin.org to the product http
bin when i refresh my page you'll see
the endpoint is bound to the api product
http bin now we can turn our attention
to the components that are going to run
on my workstation
i'll start with analytics which is
shipped by apogee
it gathers metrics from envoy that
measures the consumption of the apis
such as the number of successes
who's been invoking apis etc i'm
entering a simple script that starts the
analytics component of the adapter
and the analytics component is now
running
the next component i'm going to start is
envoy itself
before i start envoy i want to highlight
two pieces in the configuration
the prefix and how it handles requests
i'll be matching the prefix http bin
i'm configuring it such that all
requests will pass through the envoy
proxy and go to the apogee adapter
the adapter will determine whether the
consumer has access or not
and will reject those that don't have
access let's go ahead and start
envoy so now i have the analytics and
envoy component
started the last component that i need
to start is the apogee adapter for envoy
itself
this is what advises envoy whether to
allow or deny a call
and for that i've got a script here now
all three components are running
let's try and access the api endpoint
get
because i don't have a token it didn't
work and the call was rejected
let me go and get the token from apogee
once i have the token i'll rerun the
command to access the api endpoint
this time by passing the token as a
parameter
and this time around i'm able to access
the api endpoint
now let's take a look at what was in
that token
[Music]
it has the audience remote service
client
it also indicates which products the
consumer can access
in this case that's the product http bin
these elements were then enforced by
envoy
what i just showed you is how an api
consumer would access this endpoint
another way this could be done is by
publishing this endpoint and a product
on an api portal
when developers come to the api portal
they can view and access their apis
the api portal also allows developers to
grab credentials for their http bin
product the credentials are masked here
for security purposes
once developers get their credentials
they can access the api like i showed
earlier
through all these interactions analytics
are being collected and transmitted to
the apigee control panel
looking at api metrics here you'll
notice that httpbin.org is getting
requests and i can view the data for
that
this is how you can use the apogee
adapter for envoy to enforce policies
for any service that's using envoy
now that you know how it works and what
it does let me talk to you about how to
start using the apogee adapter for envoy
the easiest way to get started is from
our docs page which i've linked in the
description for this video
that's where we've outlined three
examples that you can follow to get
started
native envoy with apogee edge for public
cloud
istio sidecar with apogee hybrid and
native envoy with apogee for private
cloud
the apogee adapter for envoy can also be
used by anyone who uses istio or google
antho service mesh
to get started with those get in touch
with your google cloud account team
in summary the apogee adapter for envoy
gives you an easy way to plug api
management capabilities such as
publishing
visibility governance and usage
analytics into those services that
require them
links to more information like codelabs
and blog posts are in the description
below
and be sure to check out our other
videos and let us know what else you'd
like to learn about apogee